[Nix] ...we seek to do as a firm.
We are a behavior change agency.
The holy grail of communications is
when you can start to change behavior.
Uh, Trinidad. This is a great,
interesting case history
of how we look at problems.
[folk music playing]
[Nix]
There are two main political parties,
one for the blacks
and one for the Indians.
And you know, they screw each other.
So, we were working for the Indians.
We went to the client and we said,
"We want to target the youth."
And we try and increase apathy.
The campaign had to be non-political,
because the kids
don't care about politics.
It had to be reactive,
because they're lazy.
So we came up with this campaign,
which was all about:
Be part of the gang. Do something cool.
Be part of a movement.
And it was called the "Do So!" campaign.
[Kaiser]
It means "I'm not going to vote."
[Nix] "Do so! Don't vote."
[crowd cheering]
[man] The salute of resistance
that is known to all
across Trinidad and Tobago.
Do So! Do So!
-Do So!
-[crowd continues cheering]
[Nix] It's a sign of resistance against,
not the government,
against politics and voting.
-♪ Run with it, run with it ♪
-♪ Run, run ♪
[Nix]
They're making their own YouTube videos.
This is the prime minister's house
that's being graffitied.
It was carnage.
[Nix]
We knew that when it came to voting,
all the Afro-Caribbean kids wouldn't vote,
because they Do So!
But all the Indian kids would do
what their parents told them to do,
which is go out and vote.
They had a lot of fun doing this,
but they're not gonna go
against their parents' will.
[fireworks crackling]
[overlapping shouts]
Thank God for the guidance
that has brought us here to this victory.
Thank you. Thank you, God.
[Nix] And the difference in
18- to 35-year-old turnout was like 40%.
And that swung the election about 6%,
which was all we needed
in an election that's very close.
We now undertake ten national campaigns
for prime minister or president each year.
Malaysia, we're working in.
[Kaiser] We did Lithuania, Romania,
Kenya, Ghana.
-[Nix] So quite a few this year.
-[Kaiser] Nigeria.
-[man] The Brexit campaign?
-[Nix] Oh, and the Brexit campaign, yeah.
But we don't talk about that.
[Kaiser] Oops, we won!
[laughter]